listen this is completely Beyond parody
um a former Trump advisor named Larry
Kudlow and a right-wing media host named
Mark Levin
were uh uh uh bemoaning that Joe Biden
never criticizes Vladimir Putin and this
was within uh just a couple days of Joe
Biden saying that Vladimir Putin is a
war criminal now the the story here for
me is projection we've talked about
projection before and with modern
trumpism one of the things we always
have to at least suspect is if they
accuse the left of something we should
look really deeply at whether they are
actually doing it themselves when they
said well the left doesn't Hillary and
the left don't take care of sensitive
information
they can't be trusted
uh they're using private email we should
have said and some of us did they're
probably doing it right and indeed Jared
Kushner and Ivanka Trump were using
private email and Donald Trump was
eating and flushing and burning
classified documents including stuff
that was supposed to be kept as part of
the presidential records act taking
documents to Mar-A-Lago Etc so they were
really doing it
um we spent six months before the 2020
election with them saying Oh the left is
is going to commit fraud as Donald Trump
would say and it turned out they tried
to commit the fraud they tried to steal
the election they insisted that Joe
Biden actually stole it so when they say
x is going on what we should interpret
that as is you might be the ones doing X
and the idea of Hey listen the election
was definitely rigged we should know
we're the ones who rigged it so of
course now the new thing is becoming why
won't Biden criticize Putin which of
course in reality the problem has been
these soft and not So Soft Putin
apologists on the right so in comes
Larry Kudlow and he says to Mark Levin
why doesn't Biden just come out and
criticize Vladimir Putin it's beyond
parody let's take a look at it let me
ask you some just about Putin crazy
Putin
um who is a criminal he's an
international war criminal but why is it
Mark you and I both worked in the Reagan
Administration I never hear Biden
attack Putin
so
Kudlow literally says he's a war
criminal and that Biden never attacks
Putin here is Biden calling Putin a war
criminal for the invasion of Ukraine
[Music]
I think he is a war criminal
um these guys are living in a fantasy
world let's continue historically I mean
it took effect you want to squeeze it
out of them yeah okay finally said he's
a war criminal oh okay why doesn't Biden
ever just come out and criticize Putin
and his system and his uh War
criminality the way Reagan did to
various communist leaders what has Biden
been doing it's your former boss who
first said Putin's genius and Savvy and
clever and he's getting great land by
what he's doing and then had to walk it
back and even when walking it back he
continued to
um uh make a very very soft criticism
remember during that weird uh rally the
rally that Trump did in uh where was
this one this I guess this one was South
Carolina I don't even remember where he
talked about Putin is driven to put it
together no he's invading another
country driven to put it together listen
to this
and for all the talk about violent
conflict in Eastern Europe and it's a
terrible thing and we're gonna help and
we're going to do whatever we can
because nobody can look at the Bloodshed
much longer what's happening right it's
a lack of respect
for a lot of people it's a lack of
respect not not exactly a strong
condemnation of Vladimir Putin a lot of
things but it's just a total lack of
respect and it happens to be a man that
is just driven he's driven to put it
together and you look at it and it's
just so ridiculous that's uh not really
a very strong strong condemnation of
Putin right he's just he's a man who's
driven to put it together uh well Biden
call them a war criminal
so as usual
we have to look at their side when they
accuse the left of whatever in this case
it's why won't Biden more seriously
criticize Vladimir Putin and of course
the real concern is the Putin apologists
which included Trump although I guess
now he's not although who knows he's
still using really strange language like
he's driven to put it together uh people
like Tucker Carlson
etc etc you guys know the list and as
usual it is merely projection we have a
situation right now where many companies
want and need to hire people quickly but
it is difficult to find the right
candidates and workable is going to help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process workable helps you cast
the widest net possible by posting your
jobs to over 200 of the top job boards
with just one click it helps you
evaluate and hire quickly with modern
tools like video interviews and
e-signatures you can automate some of
those repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews whether you're hiring for
your coffee shop or your engineering
team workable is exactly what you need
to hire the right people fast start
hiring today with a risk-free 15-day
trial if you hire during the trial which
many do it will cost you nothing just go
to workable.com podcast to start hiring
the link is down below